[Music]
hello Conan O'Brien again I asked you
four questions and man did you have
questions over 5,000 questions I chose
one at random here it is it's from Lance
Peltier here's the question
Conan you probably were able to try a
lot of crazy sandwiches on all your time
off what kind of sandwiches did you eat
and which one was your favorite that's a
great question
I did have a lot of time off I love
sandwiches and I started making my own
and man Lance did I come up with a doozy
check it out you start out with a whole
loaf of bread that's important okay get
processed ham and processed turkey don't
use the real stuff it's the processing
it makes it healthy and then slobber it
right on that sandwich don't be shy I
like a lot of meat on my sandwich if you
know what I mean sounds dirty but it
doesn't really mean anything
I like Mayo so really put some mayo in
there okay
then check this out here's where we get
fancy salsa okay it's time to go south
of the border with a little salsa there
and I had a little Mexican cheese right
there gravy gotta have gravy mmm very
nice fiber is important so I add flax
plus all right
put a little fiber in there you want
this thing to move through you like
grain through a goose then I had a few
chicken McNuggets right here because
everybody loves chicken McNuggets kids
love them and you push them right in and
the gravy holds them okay that's the
beauty of it then finally right here we
just add a toy from a Happy Meal right
in there
just put it in there close it up and
that is ready to go we call this the
Conan all right now well the happy guy
came out all we have to do now is send
it to you Lance that's right I'm going
to send this sandwich to you
we only have is this FedEx tube help me
out here bleh get this - you stupid get
it in there this is coming to you Lance
we're gonna mail this to you I can't
afford to do overnight so what's going
to take probably about two weeks but
this is coming your way Lance if you
have other questions send them
facebook.com slash team Coco and I will
answer your